i got to pull up this this uh this
is amazing ladies and gentlemen i have a
very important fact check for you from
politifact um you see uh maria bartoromo
yeah
how could she she said we have doubled
our oil imports from russia in the last
year what does she think she is
mostly
politifact clarifies the u.s did not
double oil imports from russia in the
last year okay what actually happened
was according to politifact the us did
double the amount of crude oil import
from russia last year so they resist
both of those things in the same article
they meant mostly false like mostly
peaceful yeah wait wait i i actually i
have to interrupt the i hate to do this
but the crude oil is one type of various
types of oil imported to the us and so i
so we we doubled one type not oil in
general oh but she didn't even maria
barona didn't even yeah no it was it was
terribly written terribly wrong
in parentheses so when uh
when maria was talking uh she's talking
with jesse waters i believe she said we
have doubled our imports from russia in
the last year referring to generally
just oil well that's supposed to be in
brackets not in parentheses it is the
point is
her statement is correct she wasn't
speaking very specifically and
absolutely she was saying here's one
particular issue if she was referring to
crude oil it's absolutely correct but of
course the fact check just assumes that
it's going to be completely yeah why
didn't they put crude when they add look
at this they added the word oil to her
quote she did not say that they were
wrong and here's the thing too with the
mostly false you could put
like that can go either way you can say
mostly false or mostly true it could be
yeah mostly true she's magical
that's why i'm saying they're using it
the way that he's mostly peaceful mostly
is a magic word maybe means the same
thing as maybe not it has the exact same
meaning it's so blatant to the
mainstream media and these fact checkers
they're trying to trying to pretend like
and they did this in canada as well
you know when you buy oil from the
russian regime you're directly
sponsoring their war effort you're
paying for it and these mainstream media
journalists are just so desperate to
make it to gaslight canadians and
americans into thinking that that's not
yeah exactly yeah
completely intentional
um it's interesting that that's not
what's happened that's not what is
happening because they want to draw your
attention away from keystone xl this
this like obvious policy decision that
should be reversed um it never should
have been canceled in the first place
but uh the mainstream media is they're
just breathless and they're in their
support for the russian regime was the
canadian uh was the support for keystone
really really powerful and then the
americans wanted it shut down or did
everybody oh it depends where you were
in like alberta it was super like super
supportive uh western canada generally
uh was hugely supportive of this right
and then
sorry ian we don't ask the canadians
about canada we ask them about america
oh yeah i want the outside perspective
right but no continue please so i mean
lots of canadians wanted it there was no
there was no canadians really saying we
shouldn't do it the the
opposition was american leftists and and
frankly foreign funded activists in
canada because you americans absolutely
fun eco-radicals but kian you should
mention we fund you guys too what are
you talking about you should mention
that
those radical activists held and like
blocked the pipeline for years and they
had to go through the legal court
process to get them arrested get them
taken away and so people talk about the
ottawa yeah they were there for two
weeks and it was hurting industry
the people blocking the pipeline have
been there for years and they still went
through total double standard when it
comes to blocking infrastructure no no
no come on be honest guys they weren't
honking horns yeah
no they just killed like what did they
kill an rcmp officer no they actually
they this so this was a different
pipeline this was a pipeline heading
westbound up in northern bc but as the
truckers were
occupying as some people are saying or
but basically protesting in ottawa and
honking a lot there was an actual
terrorist attack in northern british
columbia for this northern gateway
for for this coastal gasline pipeline
that was going to carry liquefied
natural gas um they actually
a bunch of camouflaged men uh
radical indigenous eco-radicals funded
by americans came into this site and
trashed a bunch of vehicles burnt things
with hatchets tomahawks all the whole
shebang billions of dollars in damage
yeah but you can't compare that to
honking yeah
i mean people's ears were hurting yeah
did you have you seen an article about
the phantom honking
tell me about it
apparently it's people hearing honking
after there's no honking maybe the
trucks are just gone but people are like
actually honking experience because
that's what cars do and they're like i
can still hear them i have ptsd from the
convoy
you know but you need to understand is
these people probably do have ptsd and
here's the issue
if you are a soft
pink mask
of cookie dough
that has never experienced any hardship
and you grow up that way and your entire
world view is based on living in a
padded room of pastel colors and
sing-alongs and harry potter and star
wars
then when someone walks in and yells at
you it's traumatizing to you
you are you have so i'm half kidding but
for these people who have been you know
pampered urban you know elite types or
not even elite types but you know
they're they're they lack any kind of
hard experience
hearing those constant honkings is
stressing them out because it does two
things the first is the physical
agitation of constantly hearing the
honking i don't mean any kind of
violence but like that its presence is
physical to them but also the
psychological impact of them
being potentially wrong these are people
who are desperate to fit in and all of a
sudden there's a big popular movement
outside and they're all cheering and
dancing and screaming and you're not a
part of it
they seek refuge online where people are
like don't worry we hate them too you're
you're one of us and that makes them
feel better in their anger
so yeah some kind of trauma i suppose
and now uh yeah people are probably just
honking their horns and as soon as they
do someone probably screams and freaks
out it's happening every weekend i don't
think people realize like even when i
was going to the airport in canada there
were still people on every bridge
everyone has canadian flags on their car
cars i never realized how many people
thought like me until yesterday i didn't
realize that many canadian flags were so
it looked like fourth of july in canada
the canadian flag has become like the
american
liberals flag patriotism yeah you guys
have you guys have a maple leaf on your
flag
to make fun of our maple i was going to
say it's very cute i'm into it adorable
i wanted a turkey turkey
but then the liberals they took you know
everything that was good about our
country yeah and oh wow that was cool
yeah interesting this is better than
ever right
that was our flag world war one world
war ii well the crest was a little bit
different it changed over time but that
was the most recent version of the flag
they're the leaves now there's this one
dude how long until they put a maple
leaf on this is the first one i like the
maple syrup but i want more colors that
was the one they fought in under world
war ii i think
world war one so rad look at this
amazing canadian flag
i know how much more respect canada
would get if that was still your fault
all the people that say canada's not
part of the british empire uh check
please what can you guys tell me do a
little bit wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
let's not make it let's leave them alone
hold on hold on a minute hold on a
minute this is legit you said this is it
yeah i mean this is from wikimedia look
at this not only does it have the union
jack which is the united kingdom it's
got a crown it's got a bison i believe a
fish but also a wreath of maple leafs
yeah i've heard this three i've heard
the three leaves this could be i could
be making this up but i heard that it
represents like the three different
populations in canada like the english
the french and the indigenous cool nice
i like it
so in within that little crest the three
there there's two of them so these are a
lot of local like communities that were
these were all like the different parts
of canada
like new brunswick and all that like the
thistles
so what is this singles hold on has
generally changed when when did they
decide to ruin your country wasn't that
long ago yeah yeah it was actually quite
recent like i think maybe in the 60s
that was like my thought too but i don't
want to spread it more fake i said an
rcmp officer was killed by those
protesters i just want to clarify they
just like threw bombs at
don't think we should be so violent you
know exchange that plague and this this
is the frustrating this might be like
esoteric canadian politics but i'm from
i'm from the west uh from alberta i'm an
albertan separatist actually and
um
it's frustrating about that flag because
that's the maple leaf and there's no
maple trees west of like manitoba right
so the cities like eastern elitists uh
came and said yeah let's put the maple
leaf on the flag because that represents
canada but really that's just the
laurentian understanding of canada these
like eastern like trudeau all of these
eastern liberals have decided to sort of
usurp the understanding of canada and
replaced the union jack and all of those
that beautiful crest that obviously
represented every part of canada and
then said now we just want to use a leaf
from a tree that only exists in quebec
you know i actually really like that
this happened to the flag because it's
such a simple and concise way to explain
how they made everything dumb and
horrible in canada you're like okay well
in this time frame they took this out
they removed all the people who live in
this part of the country and now it's
just like this elitist oversimplified
kind of like a globalist they did the uh
modern corporate art yeah
it's a modern logo i mean how long
before that happens in america like
these 13 stripes represent 13 slave
colonies we need to change this flag all
together just the star what would it be
like the mcdonald's golden arches yeah
something like that it's something
corporate yeah yeah 100 no it would just
be like the star by itself maybe or i
don't know a single second they changed
the canadian flag if you add more color
i'd be down like a psychedelic flag
would be neat but i don't know canada is
going to make a psychedelic flying out
like a blue red white blue's a little
cliche what what if we added stripes
horizontal stripes and then we did like
a rainbow oh you know they've done that
oh okay
that actual flag has flown on parliament
hill
what do you guys think about symbology
in general and flags i mean because i
personally like burn the flag i don't
care yes have you ever watched boondock
saints i think once yeah does anybody
here watch boondock saints it was a cool
cartoon willem willem dafoe when the cop
is like symbology and he goes symbolism
okay i'm making up words because i'm
english that's what joe biden's joe
biden was supposed to everyone
yeah symbology is a thing i don't know a
symbol but that's like the study of
symbols exactly a study of symbols right
in general do you do you think that it's
because i find it's kind of like cult
worship like everyone worship me because
i have the icon now and if you i'm the
one that has the the
badge like i don't burn the flag if you
want to practice i disagree i think
flank is like it it is in the eye of the
beholder right like it means to people
something obviously it means something
different to everyone who sees it when i
see that canadian
we call the maple rag in alberta it you
know it it brings on ideas of of eastern
oppression uh just like you guys
probably would have felt americans back
in
1770 whatever the heck it was when you
guys threw the tea in the harbor and
decided to become a bunch of trolls 73
watch traders okay
you can go back
the big cities of canada are ripping you
guys off yeah oh absolutely because like
they tell us we can't have pipelines
they tell us we have to shut down our
oil and gas industry um they force weird
taxes on us that
make us pay for social programs in
quebec which are ridiculous when it
comes to managing their budget um so we
fund their social programs they go
deeper into debt and we have to pay for
it yeah so so before we move on i just
have to ask are you guys kind of feeling
the national divorce thing in canada as
well because it's been going on for a
while yeah trudeau and and biden as well
it's mirroring on both sides of the
border they're both saying that oh you
know we're the most united we've ever
been oh are we
and that's obviously not the case in
canada and i think i assume the united
states you should have that free spot on
the bingo i would i mean biden and
trudeau are probably more united than
ever before but the people of their
country are not the actual united under
uh klaus schwab yes exactly love that
guy he's great so come on man we had uh
one guest was saying that canada has
actually had very serious points of you
know near
near i don't know about total collapse
but like breaking apart in like the 80s
and the 90s yeah quebec it was like 49
to 51 wasn't it for secession for the
quebecois it was a couple thousand votes
it was very very tight yeah i would have
made them an independent nation yeah and
they they are very culturally different
like if you go to quebec literally it
feels like europe to some extent
they're like france's mentally
challenged cousins but is it is it is it
montreal in quebec does it speak english
so montreal is fairly like half and half
though like half kind of french kind of
english but like quebec city is isn't
like all french yeah yeah but
that's the thing that's i'm having so
much trouble because when you go to
quebec and you don't speak french
they're like horrible to you but then
all of the cool politicians are coming
from there now because they've got that
sense of nationalism like pierre
polaviere maxim bernier
actually from calgary just like ted cruz
i just said
so i'm just discriminating if they were
too if like um quebec did secede would
they be then would the british because
like i'm i'm a little it's fuzzy about
the connection between canada and the
british empire you know it's part of the
common i believe it's part of the
commonwealth yeah we were part of the
commonwealth and then so if quebec was
to secede would it still be part of the
commonwealth no they do not want to be a
part of the congress and then with the
british like just send in the royal you
know the canadian mountain police or
whatever and come in
the king says there was a supreme court
ruling that like the clarity act is what
it was called and it allowed for
any place in canada basically to
separate if there was a clear margin and
a clear question when it came to
secession and
it's a big question whether or not
quebec would have met that if they were
over 50 or not but at the end of the day
they weren't they were 49 so nobody
really knows but if they were you know
say 60 of them voted to leave there's a
supreme court ruling that says we can do
it for 49 oh they needed 60 well they
needed more than 50 of these and they
got 49. yeah thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you